if you were following the trial of kyle
rittenhouse on social media you might
have come to the conclusion that judge
schroeder was a hopelessly biased
nutcase who was making up all the rules
to help kyle rittenhouse
was he
[Music]
now most of the situations that people
are objecting to involve the application
of the rules of evidence in state court
the judge has broad discretion to make
rulings on the admissibility of evidence
and how to run their courtroom this
includes things like which witnesses are
allowed to testify what the lawyers are
allowed to ask what topics are off
limits and a whole bunch of other things
and there were a few incidents that
stuck out so let's talk about incident
number one where judge schroeder ruled
that the prosecution could not call the
people that kyle rittenhouse shot and
killed victims the defense attorneys
argued that using the word victim could
prejudice the jury against written house
judge schroeder said the word victim is
a loaded loaded word when the judge
ruled in favor of the defendant critics
jumped to the conclusion that judge
schroeder was showing inappropriate
favoritism to written house now trial
judges have lots of discretion the
wisconsin rules of evidence mostly track
the federal rules of evidence even if
particular evidence isn't explicitly
ruled out judges have lots of leeway
wisconsin rule of evidence 904.03 which
is very similar to federal rule of
evidence 403 states quote although
relevant evidence may be excluded if its
probative value is substantially
outweighed by the danger of unfair
prejudice confusion of the issues or
misleading the jury or by considerations
of undue delay waste of time or needless
presentation of cumulative evidence in
other words evidence might be minimally
relevant but if the risk of prejudice is
too great you shouldn't allow that
evidence into the courtroom and the way
the victim is used in a courtroom is
different than what's used outside of
the courthouse written house claimed
that he was acting in self-defense if he
was right the three men would not be
considered victims in the legal sense of
the word they would be assailants who
attacked rittenhouse people also
suggested that judge schroeder was
making up special rules just for written
house but the judge's ruling was
consistent with the way that he handles
criminal trials according to the kenosha
news quote that is schroeder's standard
practice in criminal cases and is not
unique to this handling of the written
house case criminal lawyers said these
rulings were commonplace in their
jurisdictions as well victims suggest
guilt before it is proven and
prosecuting and convicting someone is
hard as well it should be and of course
it's always okay to refer to these
people by their names which tactically
can be even better because it humanizes
them in a court of law a criminal
defendant must be given his full due
process rights the whole object of a
fair trial is not to prejudge the
defendant that means judges should be
skeptical of evidence that a jury could
use to infer someone's guilt if that
evidence is not truly probative of what
happened and that brings us to the
second incident where judge schroeder
ruled that the three men who were shot
could be referred to as rioters looters
and arsonists well specifically what
judge schroeder said was let the
evidence show what the evidence shows
that any or one of these people were
engaged in arson riding or looting that
i'm not going to tell the defense they
can't call them that prosecutor thomas
binger said that this was a double
standard quote i think it's the exact
same issue the terms that i'm
identifying here such as rioters looters
arsonists are as loaded if not more
loaded than the term victim first a
defendant generally gets to put on
whatever defense they want so
a court should err on the side of
allowing a defendant to do something and
get more freedom than the prosecution
but second of all judge schroeder did
not rule that the defense could
absolutely call the men rioters and
looters he ruled that if the defense
could prove that the three men were
rioting and looting then they could use
those terms during the closing argument
and the judge prohibited the defense
from using those terms during their
opening statement very similar to the
ruling he made about the word victim
neither side could use those terms
unless they prove their case that takes
us to incident number three where judge
schroeder dressed down the prosecutor
saying don't get brazen with me judge
schroeder was again accused of bias when
he blew up at prosecutor thomas binger
first of all yes judges do yell at
lawyers and sometimes those lawyers
deserve it some do it more frequently
than others and kenosha lawyers say that
schroeder is definitely a yeller now
second the judge sent the jury out of
the room before admonishing the
prosecutor and third and most
importantly we should look to what
caused schroeder to blow his top when
rittenhouse took to the stand to testify
in his own defense the prosecutors
seemed to refer to written house's prior
silence about what happened quote since
august 25 2020 this is the first time
that you have told your story that's
what the prosecutor asked on the stand
the defense immediately objected and
schroeder sustained the objection
disallowing the question and there's
good reason for that in criminal cases
the fifth amendment protects against
self-incrimination among other things
this means that a defendant's decision
not to talk can't be used against them
the judge sustained the objection
because binge question was too close to
the line but then bingo basically asked
the same question a different way he
referred to the many months of people
talking about the case and said quote
after all of that now you are telling us
your side of the story correct it seems
that what binger was getting at was that
because written house hadn't testified
before and was now testifying after
everyone else had taken the stand and
after all of the evidence had come out
that rittenhouse was now in a position
where he could change his story and
craft it to be consistent with everyone
else's testimony but of course
a question can be two things at once and
if it's too prejudicial even if there is
some probative value to it well then the
court can still disallow it which the
court specifically had done it schroeder
had disallowed it so judge schroeder
asked the jury be removed so that he
could basically just yell at binger
you need to account for this
the problem is this is a grave
constitutional violation
for you to talk about the defendants
silence
and that is and and in your right
you're right on the you're right on the
borderline
and you may
you may be over but it better stop in
other words it doesn't matter whether
you think rittenhouse was guilty or not
in the context of a criminal trial his
post-arrest silence couldn't be used
against him binger said he understood
but then to add insult to injury he then
plunged into a series of questions about
a matter the judge had already
previously ruled was off limits a video
where written house fantasized about
shooting alleged shoplifters which takes
us to incident number four the judge
ruled that the prosecution could not
show a video showing written house
saying that he wished he could shoot two
people leaving a cvs store now the
background is that before trial the
prosecution moved to introduce evidence
of a video where rittenhouse says he
wished he could shoot two people who
were suspected shoplifters the
prosecutor said the video was relevant
to written house's state of mind and
motive he said britain house was quote
essentially a teenage vigilante
involving himself in things that don't
concern him now the judge excluded the
video on the grounds that the video
wasn't made before the riots it was
recorded two weeks earlier and the judge
felt that in another video which
allegedly showed written house
assaulting a girl who was in a fight
with her sister was also not relevant to
what ridden house did on august 20th
2020 in kenosha the video suggested
written house had a propensity for
violence but neither video had anything
to do with the protest now it's
important to note that judges are
arbiters and are supposed to protect the
rights of a criminal defendant and
certainly these videos make written
house look bad but we aren't supposed to
convict people for looking bad the judge
was limiting the evidence so that the
only evidence the jury heard had to do
with what actually happened on august
20th when rittenhouse encountered the
three men now crim law 101 is that you
can't or at least generally you can't
because you know there are always
exceptions you can't use propensity
evidence to show someone committed a
crime on a specific day you can show
that they committed the crime at issue
but you're not allowed to convict them
because they had a certain propensity
towards crime generally speaking a
criminal defendant can't be convicted
just because they have a history of
doing bad things the state still has to
prove that they committed the crimes
they were charged with and so when judge
schroeder yelled don't get brazen with
me it was the culmination of two
mistakes by the prosecutor referring to
written house's post arrest silence
after being told not to and referring to
the cvs videotape despite being told not
to binger felt that the defense had
opened the door and it was now okay to
go into that subject area but even if
that were the case you still need to get
permission from the judge or face their
wrath and binge still had a hard time
letting it go quote this was the subject
of emotion i'm well aware of that and
the court left the door open but judge
schroeder screamed for me not for you
you should have come and asked for
reconsideration all trial lawyers know
that if you appear to disregard a
judge's order you're probably going to
get it and to the judge's credit while
we all got to see schroeder lambast the
prosecutors on the live feed the jury
was sequestered away and would have been
completely unaware so it wouldn't have
prejudiced the prosecution's case that
takes us to incident number five judge
schroeder allowed rittenhouse to pick
his own jurors
well not exactly judge schroeder had
written house blindly pick the 12 jurors
who would be deciding his case out of a
hat it's weird but in wisconsin and
other states the courts regularly seek
more jurors than necessary because at
the end of trials it's common for jurors
to be stricken from the panel for
various reasons this could be
for misconduct or a juror having a
family emergency or just getting sick in
the written house trial 18 prospective
jurors heard all the evidence after
closing arguments the judge told
rittenhouse to randomly pick six numbers
out of a tumblr those six numbers were
stricken from the panel the 12 who were
left were his jury whittling down the
jurors is not unusual picking them out
of a hat is somewhat unusual
judge schroeder said he'd have
defendants do this election for years he
said that responding to critics he
started doing it after a case where
there was only one prospective black
juror that person was eliminated from
the jury when the clerk picked that
juror's name out of the the panel that
resulted in a black defendant being
tried by an all-white jury as a result
of one of the court administrators judge
schroeder felt that that was not ideal
he said quote it was a bad optic i
thought i think people feel better when
they have control so ever since that
case i have had an almost universal
policy of having the defendant do the
picks when only one part of judge
schroeder's explanation was
cherry-picked and then circulated among
social media it looked terrible but
actually it seems like his explanation
makes perfect sense while this process
is a little bit theatrical
the reasons for doing so actually
empower the defendant
and it's hard to imagine that there
would be any prejudice to either the
defense or the prosecution as a result
of this particular foible that takes us
to incident number six the judge
disallowed zooming in on a video well
not exactly judge schroeder was mocked
for sustaining a defense objection to
zooming in on video footage via an ipad
this was presented as either a nefarious
plot between the defense lawyers and the
judge or as evidence that the judge was
old and out of touch now it's not that
the judge said that they couldn't zoom
in at all the judge just ruled that the
prosecution could zoom in on images as
long as they had an expert testify as to
how the pinch and zoom worked on an
apple device to make sure that that
process wasn't adulterating the evidence
now the prosecution couldn't produce an
expert on short notice so the jury wound
up seeing the video on a windows machine
hooked up to a tv now this was kind of a
ticky tacky objection by the defense but
in fairness lawyers are required to
authenticate an item of evidence and
this applies to every piece of evidence
that's introduced including government
records business records photographs
video audio you name it but look the
prosecution has the burden of proof so
it's on them to make sure that what
they're doing if they are changing the
evidence in any way isn't adulterating
the underlying evidence and of course
there was also an issue with drone
footage where
a file was smaller than it should have
been and that takes us to the next
incident where the judge apparently
asked the jury to applaud for a defense
witness well sort of this one is
interesting on veterans day judge
schroeder decided to recognize anyone in
the courtroom who had served in the
armed forces quote i just want to
observe that it's veterans day and any
veterans in the room on the jury or
anywhere else when no one responded the
judge said well that's unusual not to
have at least someone in here but dr
black is
what branch he was referring to the
defense witness john black who was about
to take the stand black is a use of
force expert who told the judge that he
had served in the army the judge then
said okay i think we can have a round of
applause to the people who have served
our country the entire courtroom
applauded including members of the jury
this one was just sloppy and completely
unnecessary it seemed to have the
unintended effect of bolstering the
reputation of dr black before he took
the stand who happened to be a defense
witness but it was just completely
unnecessary to run that risk for you
know a little grandstanding in this
particular case and then there were
accusations that judge schroeder was
just unusually chummy with written house
and wanted to see him acquitted for
example there's a picture of
the judge and written house being very
close together as they're watching a
video but equally likely is that
schroeder was just a relatively
pro-defendant judge and of course
there's a wide disparity between uh
criminal defendants who are remanded to
custody and those who are out on their
own recognizance rittenhouse was able to
attend not in shackles not uh going back
to prison and in a suit we don't want to
make things too easy on the prosecutor
maybe the answer here is that criminal
defendants more often should get the
benefit of the doubt like written house
did but more pragmatically if a judge
doesn't err on the side of the defense
they are likely to see an appeal and no
trial judge wants to a get reversed by
the court of appeals and b have to retry
a defendant and that's one reason why
they might err on the side of
disallowing evidence that might
otherwise come in to make sure that
there aren't other constitutional
violations and for better or worse
schroeder was clearly paying attention
to how the trial was covered quote when
i talked about problems with the media
when this trial started were there in
part not fully but in part because of
grossly irresponsible handling of what
comes out of this trial i will tell you
this i'm going to think long and hard
about live television of a trial again
next time i don't know i've always been
a firm believer in it because i think
the people should be able to see what's
going on but what i see what's being
done is really quite frightening
frightening that's the right word for it
now i can't imagine how he possibly got
that impression which takes us to the
final incidents schroeder had a racist
cell phone ringtone come on people a
cell phone ringtone really come on
you're better than this but also judge
schroeder dude turn your cell phone off
in court that is rule number one now
there is no doubt that schroeder is a
crotchety old man but maybe that's just
because his cell phone plan is too
expensive he's getting calls all the
time even when he's in court he could
have saved a ton of money by switching
to today's sponsor ting mobile in fact i
personally switched to mobile and saved
literally hundreds of dollars a month
i'm not kidding why well because of this
yes that is a real cell phone bill that
i got with my previous provider and
that's why i personally switched to ting
and team mobile has three brand new
plans to make sure that never happens
again and all of ting's plans have
unlimited talk and tech starting at just
ten dollars per month so you can use the
flex plan and only pay for what you use
which is especially great if you're
around wi-fi all day but you can also
choose a set of 12 gigabytes of data for
35 or get a full unlimited plan for 45 a
month switching plans is really easy
because you can keep your same phone
number and use pretty much any phone and
the service is great too because ting
partners with several massive networks
probably the very same one that you're
using right now but at a huge discount
they literally use the same
infrastructure now i actually can't tell
you which ones because i always respect
contracts but let's just say that my
service hasn't changed at all and ting
still gives you the option to just pay
for what you use with their flex plan
now they just give you the possibility
of an unlimited plan as well so if you
want unlimited you can go absolutely
crazy and it's incredibly easy to
transfer service just by simply ordering
a ting sim card popping it in and
setting it up no phone call is even
required but if you do want to talk to
ting since they don't have brick and
mortar stores you can call them up and
immediately talk to real human beings or
chat via instant message or discord
you'll talk to real human beings not ai
robots so if you'd like to give ting a
try legal eagles will get a free 25
service credit that could cover two
months of service all you have to do is
just click on the link below and give it
a try you can even use your last bill to
compare just how much you would save so
click on the link that's on screen right
now or the one that's in the description
you'll get a free 25 service credit plus
clicking on those links really helps out
this channel and while you're there
check out this playlist with all my
other real law reviews on the most
important legal issues of the day so
click on this playlist or i'll see you
in court